trophy's the single greatest word to any
self-respecting videogame completionist
the satisfaction the little ping noise
gives you and sometimes more
exhilarating than the game itself but
there are some trophies which even we
are a little bit embarrassed to have on
our game account with that in mind here
are eight outrageous and shameful things
we've done for a Playstation trophy at
number eight is the I swear I did it by
mistake trophy in comedy horror game
lollipop chainsaw and you get this for
carefully maneuvering the camera in an
attempt to look up juliet styling skirt
surprisingly I didn't need a trophy
guide for this one that's the world
across it on my own first chamber
completed continue testing at number
seven is the you made your point trophy
from the masterpiece we call portal 2 to
obtain this bronze trophy simply stand
around in Chapter eight and refuse to
solve this puzzle impossible as it is to
imagine there actually is a solution
devilishly hidden
after he has variety for long law the
trophy will eventually pop up okay so
that one wasn't too outrageous so let's
move things forward on to the innuendo
field pile of crap game that we call
Duke Nukem Forever the game itself is
terrible but the one-liners and
ridiculous trophies made begin somehow
satisfying for instance the turd burglar
trophy you get this trophy for grabbing
a stale lump of excrement out of the
toilet and launch it across the room
even Duke isn't on board with this one
what the hell No come on No
this is disgusting what kind of sick
mother picks up wet feces since Roe the
third is at number five on the list for
a France trophy named owl my balls for
this trophy you need to punch the enemy
in the groin could we want once you do
this once it's difficult to play any
other way winning is the best thing at
number four on our list is the sexting
trophy from Metal Gear Solid 2 when
snake is asked to photograph a weapon of
mass destruction he can instead opt to
locate a soldier in the crowd who is
without his trousers by sending the
photo to Otacon you are awarded with the
trophy and a hugely immune topic on so
any codec moments from you snake okay
first up
this rules but we can't use it get the
shots we need number three on our list
is the interface trophy from Borderlands
2 this shaded classic has some hugely
quirky characters including Doge that
robot claptrap but one other character
named Facebook shootie has the best
cameo in our eyes when approached he
begs you to when you're good and ready
simply pull the trigger and the trophy
is yours
second on the list is the
gut-wrenchingly tedious kill on trophy
found in gta5 this nineteen steps silver
trophy has you giving your money away
searching for your four pieces and
stealing vehicles but the most
ridiculous section has you dressed in
futuristic biblical robes and forced to
run around the desert for five miles
there's no way to avoid this you really
have to run around aimlessly for 10
minutes we've reached the top of the
list our most shameful trophy comes from
Red Dead Redemption for the ps3 the
trophy is named dusted Lee and rewards
you for throwing your moral compass out
of the window now you must find a
helpless young lady hog-tie her and
place her on the train tracks ready for
the 3:10 to Yuma then sit back and watch
as her body explodes into red vapor you
evil bastard
so that was our list of outrageous and
shameful things we've done for a
Playstation trophy did we miss any of
your favorites if so please pop them in
the comments below as always please like
and share if you've enjoyed wasting time
with us see you next time